hello i'm matthias and the founder
of datatec in this video i'll explain to
you in a simple way everything to do with the
test for independent samples and how
you can easily calculate the text online with
datatec let's start at
the beginning of the perpetrator there are three variants
the  simple culprit the culprit is for
independent samples the test for
dependent samples the simple test
is used to check whether there is a
difference between a group and
the population this test
is often used in
quality assurance, for
example to check whether a
produced screw  on average really has
the given weight the
independent test is used to
test if there is a difference between
two independent samples for
example there is a difference
between the salary of males and
females the offender is for dependent samples
is used to test if there is
with two dependent samples
So there is a difference in random samples where
a person was interviewed at two points in time, for example.
This video is about the test for
independent random samples. In the
description of this video you will find
the links to my videos and tutorials
about the other offenders or
just throw  a look at date up en now
you are probably wondering what is the
difference between an independent
and a dependent
sample independent samples result
from independent person and
measurement a person in this sample
has nothing to do with a person in this
sample these two samples  are completely
independent in the case of dependent
samples, the measured values ​​are in pairs the
pairs result, for example, from
repeated measurements in the same people, i.e.
this person is the
same as this person and this
person is the same as this person
an example of this would be if we were from
a person that
measure the weight of the independent
perpetrator before and after the cure let's look at this case,
namely independent stitch
now the question is, of course, what
do i need an independent perpetrator for is
let's say i want to check whether there is a
difference between two groups in the
population, for example there
is  a difference in the salary of
men and women
now it is of course not possible
to ask all men and women about their salary,
so we take a sample, so
we create a survey and send
this random person to it to now
use this sample to make a
statement about the  to
meet the population we need the independent
perpetrator is therefore only through the
independent test can we make
a statement about the population based on this sample
the question for an independent
perpetrator is therefore there is a
statistically significant difference
between the mean value of two groups
d  It can be, for example,
there is a difference between
people with and without a degree in terms
of their health, or
two production plants produce screws of
the same weight, or have
a higher risk of heart attack than
non-
smokers  can answer
for the independent perpetrator is of
course we also need a hypothesis the
hypotheses are
assumptions about reality, the validity of which is
possible but not yet proven
hypotheses always appear in pairs there
is a zero hypothesis on the one hand and the zero
hypothesis on the other  on the other hand the
alternative hypothesis the null hypothesis
assumes that there is
no difference between two groups with regard to
a specific characteristic, for example
the salary of men and women
does not differ in germany
the alternative hypothesis in the
independent test, on the other hand, assumes
that  s that there is a difference between
two groups, e.g. the salary of
men and women differs in
Germany, furthermore,
one differentiates whether a hypothesis is directed or
redirected, this plays a
major role in the interpretation of the results at the very end
, but more on that later
what is an undirected and what is
a directed
the undirected hypotheses check whether there is
a difference, it doesn't matter
in which direction the connection or
the difference goes, for example there
is a difference between the
salary of men and women it is
not said in which direction  direction of this
difference or there is a
difference in the heart attack risk
between smokers and non-smokers
but it is not said whether the
heart attack risk of smokers is higher
than that of non-smokers
accordingly there are the directional
hypotheses these also indicate the
direction of the difference  for
example, men earn more than
brown smokers or smokers have a higher risk of
heart attack than non-smokers
so we now come to the next rush
the prerequisite for the independent
perpetrator is there is an independent
variable e.g. gender which has two
characteristics, for example the
male groups  and female
that is very important the variable but
only has two characteristics if it has more
than two characteristics the test
can no longer be calculated these two
groups should become clear during the
analysis the question is is there
a difference between the two
groups in terms of the  dependent
variables, for example income the
prerequisites for the independent test
are the two group
relationships samples must be
independent the variables must be
interval escalated the variables
must be normally distributed and the
variance within the groups should be
similar
now let’s look at each of the  vi  he
points again briefly
let's start with the first point the
two group relationship samples
must be independent as the name of the
perpetrator already indicates the sample must be
independent
this means that a person evaluating one
sample must not have any influence on a
value in the other sample
So, for example, it would be correct to
measure the weight of
people who have been on a diet and people who
have not been on a diet. It would be wrong to
measure the weight of a person before
and after a certain diet. In the
second case, it would be one and the
same person and  accordingly we would have
a dependent sample
in the above case we have an
independent sample because we
interview people who have been on a diet and
interview people who have not been on a
diet the second requirement is the
variables must be white checkered
in the test for independent
samples  the mean of the sample
be calculated this is only
meaningfully possible if the
variable is checked behind white in the world
loses eg the weight of a person
does not intervene is the
educational qualification of a person with for
example secondary school Realschule and so
on and so forth
the third requirement is that the
variables  must be normally distributed
the perpetrator is responsible for independent
random samples delivers the most accurate
results if the data of the groups are
each normally
distributed there are exceptions in special cases, however
, as a rule, for example,
the weight, age or height of
a person are normally distributed not
normally distributed  the number of points after
throwing a die the fourth
requirement is the variance within
the groups should be similar
the test statistics that require the
variance must be the same within the
groups, for example the
weight, age or height of a
person who was whole  not equal
for example, if you look at the
stock market prices in normal times and in
a recession,
we have now
gone through the prerequisites and we now come to
how one can calculate an offender for independent samples.
for the calculation, we first
have to know whether the variance in  in
one group is the same as the variance
in the other group or whether the
differences in one group are different
than the variance in the other group,
so in this case we would have the
same variant, for example, in that case
we would have unequal variance now
the question is of course from where  do i know if
the variance is equal unequal for this
there is the levin test for variance equality
how can it be checked now
the variants are homogeneous i.e. variance equality
is present the levin test helps here
the levin test checks whether several
samples have the same variance
or not we have  calculating a levin test
we keep a value at a p value
If the levin test is greater than 0 05, you can
assume the variance is equal.
Otherwise, you assume no war jahns equality.
I'll show you
a date up later where you
could easily calculate it at the same time,
so let's start with the calculation for
unequal variants
here we have group 1 and
group 2 and we want to check if
the two mean values ​​of these groups are the
same for this we first calculate
the value the t value is
calculated by taking the mean value of
group 1 as - the mean value of the
other group and  then we
need the standard deviation the
mean difference the
standard deviation the mean
difference is found using this formula
where 1 is 1 and 2 is the sample
size sp is the estimated value for the
standard deviation the estimated value for
the standard deviation is
found using this formula if we
combine all of this  the tea obtained
is obtained via this formula  don't worry that
a father usually calculates the
statistics program for you
, we also need the degrees of freedom the degrees of
freedom result in 1 1
percent 2 - 2 we have the value and the degrees of
freedom we
can calculate the ph value from here or the
statistics software can turn off  these
two values ​​are the p value for
you if you have any questions about the p value
just watch a great
video about the ph value
there you will get a precise explanation of
what the p value is and how it
could be interpreted now we get to the point
how to calculate the test for independent
samples with the same variance
so again we have two
groups group 1 group 2 and we
want to know if the mean of
these two groups is different
but the variance of the two
groups is the same in this case
the value is about them  formula we
have again the mean value of the
first group the mean value of the
second group  uppe the standard deviation of the
first group and the standard deviation of
the second group and the size of the
first group and the size of the 2
we also need the
degrees of freedom again and with the t value and
the degree of freedom we can then
or the statistics
software can then calculate the ph value  calculate
so and now we come back to the
very important point whether we calculate a
one-sided or a two-sided
perpetrator for independent samples
we calculate a
two-sided test
so we have the rejection notice left and right
so if we assume a
significant level of 5 percent
then then  we have a
retention range of 95 percent and the five percent
are then split up once on the left
side and once on the right
side so we have 25 and 42 5 percent here,
however, if we want to calculate a
one-sided or a
targeted perpetrator we have
a retention  area n  oh,
still 95 percent and a
rejection notice of five percent because
we
don't have to split this area of ​​representation, we have
five percent here on the right-hand side and
don't have to split it up. the statistics
software always calculates a
double-sided culprit,
so it always assumes that  that if
you have a significant level of 5
percent, you have 25 percent on one
side and 25 percent on the other
side, you want to calculate a one-sided
or targeted perpetrator,
you first have to check whether the
result goes in the direction that
I want  and then i
also have to divide the ph value by two
so he now wants to show how he could easily calculate the
culprit for independent random samples
online with data tab to
calculate a test for an
independent random sample online very easily
, first of all you realize  day.de
then click on the
statistics calculator in st  statistic calculator
you will then see this table if you want to use
your own data
just click on table teachers and you can
then copy your data here it is
important that the variable names are in the first row
i will
just use the example data as i
said in the  the variable names must be in the first row
because below you can see
that the variable names
appear that you copied here in this table 1
we want to calculate a perpetrator
so just click on
the tab perpetrators say we want to
check whether gender has an influence
on the income has so just click here
on the income and the
gender datatec now automatically
indicates that in this case we can only
calculate one independent perpetrator we
can still choose whether it should be a
parametric test or a
non-parametric test we can also
non-parametric  test will click
the macnews it calculates
this needs  If the
prerequisites are not met
for this small sample data set
, the prerequisites will certainly
not be met,
but I would still like to show you
how you can calculate independent offenders
if you want, you can also
click prerequisite checks and
then your prerequisites will be checked here
above  can you never foresee your significance
in this case let's just leave
the 0.05 in the upper half of the
table tier now the descriptive
statistics
you keep the mean value of the
men's income here keep the
mean value of the women's income
would have the standard deviation and the
standard error of the mean is on
the right side you can see another box
plot here you can see the leaf winters
for variance equality
this value is greater than 0 05
so we can assume that both
groups have the same variance if
you want you can click here  also
click on interpretation  n and you get
an interpretation of this result,
as we can see here, so
the variance in the two samples is the same,
so if you don't
know exactly how to interpret the ph value
, simply
click on interpretation,
so we come to the last table,
the table  from the independent perpetrator
is what we are actually interested in
we find here
first of all we have to choose at
do we want to have the results if
the variants are the same or if the
variants are not the same we
said in this case our
variants are the same so we use
these  series in this case we
get a value of 0 082 since we
chose a significant level of 0.05
we cannot reject the null hypothesis
and the new hypothesis
is retained if this
is a bit too complicated for
you you can also click
summary above  in words click,
the male group had lower
scores for  the variable income as the
female group the levin test of
variance equality showed that
freedom equality
can be assumed
an offender is assumed to have the same variants for independent samples
showed that this difference was
not statistically significant
you can now
easily calculate an independent offender online with datatec  and
so you now know how a test for
independent samples is and how you
can easily calculate it online if
you don't know data tab
just google for datatec on
datatec you will find great tutorials and you can evaluate
your data directly online in
no time at all if  you
want to be informed as soon as a
new video comes out from me just complain about
the channel and click on the
blades
thank you and see you next time